hi my name is Chris Regan I'm a
screenwriter I wrote my first script
when I was 17 and then 36 so what
working right now is a script for a web
series which I'm also filming and it's
sort of a transmedia kind of project
that I started probably about a year and
a half ago because I started to get
interested in you tube and and vlogging
and what was going on with these people
who talk about their lives on camera
like this yeah so that's where it came
from when it's kind of it started as
this kind of fasting horror thing with
the conceit being that it's it's
presented as a real vlog the idea of
presenting to me is real and creating
this character and putting her out in
the world and and say here's a real
person and I'm watching the story unfold
and watching real people interact with
that story I found really exciting and
also the whole thing is about identity
and online identity and storytelling and
and how we tell stories all the time
through social media even though we
don't realize we're telling stories and
that kind of thing
I try to get more people involved as
soon as I could even though when the
script wasn't written in fact I started
casting it when I didn't have a script
which was a mistake but it pushed me to
finish the scripts so every point when
I've kind of gone early on when are
still developing you like could have
still quit I was getting people involved
and that would kind of push me to go
further and actually even worth filming
I keep adding more people to the cast's
and more people to the crew and it kind
of the more people are involved the more
difficult becomes to quit because all
these people have put work into it now
and it's it's got its own momentum
my goal with this is just to explore
ideas the attractive element means that
you never quite know what's going to
happen next likely video we get
different reactions to it and that kind
of that's why the script isn't finished
I've got a draft of it but I keep
rewriting it I rewrite the episodes as
we film because it kind of has to be
based on what's happened before and you
never quite know how the audience is
going to react designs
there's this sort of ideas screenwriting
the very kind of isolated solitary or
form and I think if you believe that and
if you practice that then that's wrong
because it is not really like i said
it's it's not screenwriting as part of
filmmaking and unless you kind of get
out into the world and whether that's
just and have to be making a film
whether that's just getting some friends
around to read through the script and do
a script reading whether that's we're
getting a short film made like well like
you don't have to do what I'm doing and
kind of like direct and produce it all
but there are ways to get your projects
made I think you know when if you just
sit there and write script after
scripture to script and then hope for
the best and I hope that kind of and
enter all the competitions and enter all
the sort of pitching things and all that
like yes that works out for some people
it's I've had some success with that
before as well like your kind of hoping
to win the lottery that way so not what
it's about like I do think the
screenwriting and filmmaking and even
though people will tell you it's about
money in business in the little bit it's
a it's about oh really and that's why
you can't just sitting room and right
under the scripts and hope that one of
those scripts will get the right person
and get making you win the lottery and
have a career like I think you have to
be doing something because you have to
be able to enjoy the journey of being a
screenwriter hate that word but you do
have to kind of find a way to enjoy that
journey and as much as you might live
right 6am sitting there writing a script
that's not that's a very kind of small
part of the journey like the lesson I've
learned is you need to sort of step away
from the computer sometimes
I used to always write at night soz i
had kids and also got older writing
easily became more difficult so now I
most the right on the train and in sort
of cafes you have to be able to write
anywhere I think
I would love to be able to work as as a
writer and not have to do a day job
that's that's up there but I don't think
that is as important as as working on
and producing interesting stuff what I'd
really like to do more anything else is
focus on writing horror films because
that's why I was into guess I worked on
the script a few years ago and it was a
romantic comedy script the producer and
I had a really different with different
sense of humor there is a there was a
line in the script group of lads and one
of them had just annoyed his girlfriend
and the main character condoms as our
what's what's happened I don't know she
muttered something is about misanthropy
and and walked off and and the main guy
says that you mean massagin feel like
there was then another punch line
because I'm not terribly funny joke was
that the sort of the guy had never heard
the word misogyny before would never be
able to understand why this woman was
angry because it's all his scripts that
got to the stage where we were going
through it line by line once at one
point and he kept saying what I don't
get this scene like I don't understand
what it's not funny so I kept just
rewriting the lies keeping this sort of
misanthropy misogyny bin and just
changing the context in the making it
really obviously one point has felt it
out I know if you seen Charlie Brown's
Christmas wazzup it where Schroeder's
playing jingle bells on the on the piano
and I often think screen joints can
write things like that like you're
trying to get like you write this
amazing really subtle bit of dialogue
and people don't get it so you just
super fight it's a fight and expand it
until it's like this long on the page
and then people get yes that's it he
just kept did not get it what is it
what's the problem what are you getting
and then why we never had this
conversation before but this is like a
fifth meeting about it and he said I
just don't know what that word means I
don't know what was our journey why
didn't google it but like what was
hilarious about it was that
the joke in the script was that this guy
had never heard the word and I'm dealing
with you so he never the word either
sailor that's a story for my
screenwriting cream